david peterson trying for a third
straight positive outing a good start in
his last outing but he didn't factor in
the decision two strikes to herrera
he'll be followed by rhys hoskins and
bryce harper and a curveball hits him
so he's aboard to start the ball game
3-2 coming grounded down to third a
chance for two guillorymate and mcneal
and on the first double play by a 4-3
double play for the first two outs of
the game
one-two coming
chopper past the mound lindora waits on
it
side retired
scoreless first for peterson mets come
to bat with no score
moore was placed on the injured list on
the 21st of may with low back spasms his
last rehab start for lehigh valley he
went six innings allowed five hits and
three runs struck out seven
swinging a miss
he gets him with a change up
and one out here in the first
out to center field
oh doubles there and
he's under it to make the catch for the
second out that was toward the end of
the bat was good pitch
2-2 pitch coming
towering fly ball out to left mccutcheon
is there he waits
[Applause]
the beginning is over one two three good
start for matt moore
and the one two from peterson swung out
and missed strike three got him with a
fast ball up
peterson has his first strikeout
three two coming to williams and he
grounds one down to third euromay waits
on the second hop and throws him out to
end the inning peterson keeping the ball
on the ground
no score going to the bottom of the
second
and he misses low ball four and guillory
is on with the walk that's first base
runner in this game albert el mora
junior coming up three and two
ah flagged all the left it's fairly deep
mccutchen's back he jumps and he made
the catch
off the top of the wall andrew mccutchen
just saved the inning for the phillies
that's right
nothing to it little walk in the park is
what that was
back toward the middle and a base hit
from marshawn he may have broken his
back but he'll take it for a hit
heck yeah he will
and he struck him out with the fastball
away
second strikeout for peterson
patrick mazzeka shoots one the other way
and he's got the mets first hit of the
game
so zika making just his second career
start as his fourth career hit to the
mets of the lead-off man on in the third
[Applause]
popped up
bald in foul territory
and he makes the catch
lifts that one in the air to right
not deep harper coming in and makes the
catch
the inning is over no runs one hit and a
man left in scoring position we're
through three
[Applause]
ball four so the phillies have a lead
off batter board
flies this one out to center and it
should be easy for almora
[Applause]
and that retires the side
a walk and error and one left halfway
through the second game mets in philly's
no score
peanuts went up the middle that's a base
hit
so for the second straight inning the
mets get a lead off in against matt
moore didn't have the shift on against
alonso and he got the base hit where
sometimes the second baseman is playing
bouncer back to the bow moore's got it
and he zips it over to first in time
williams lays down the bun peterson
springs after it and the throw into the
runner but he got him oh wow
terrific play by alonso reaching into
the runner and getting the out
i'll tell you what nice play by peterson
he was a cat off that mound off-balance
throw
nice play pedo is on the line too nicely
done all the way around and you know it
even after he caught it williams ran
into his glove
to reyes flight out to center his first
time up
and he hits one toward the hole lenore
cuts it off spins around in time two out
defense
two nice plays to start this fifth
nine outs on the ground now for peterson
of the 14 he's accumulated
the inside quarter he gets more to end
the end of his third strikeout that's
come up at the bottom of the fifth in
game two no score
[Music]
swinging a foul tip and moore has a
strikeout
out to right field right at harper and
he makes the catch no runs one hit one
man left five solid it is for matt moore
two two coming
and he struck him out with a backflip
slider
fourth strikeout for peterson two down
in the six two real good sliders in that
bat the first one to get ahead and the
last one to put him away now the bases
are empty for bryce harper
fly ball out toward right center field
that's well hit pillars going back it is
gone
home run for bryce harper
a solo homer and the phillies have taken
the lead here at the top of the sixth
inning
it's another solo home run
it's his 11th straight to start the year
that establishes a brand new phillies
franchise record but who cares they're
on top one-nothing
runner goes swing and miss and boehm is
struck out to end the inning
but bryce harper's home run breaks the
scoreless deadlock harper's 11th of the
year gives the phillies a one-nothing
lead
that's up the middle and another base
hit for alonso you know the phillies
don't want to shift against him pete
finds that same hole and he's got his
second head of the game
oh two pitch coming
grounder back to the box brogden's got
it to second for one good feed over to
first in time
a one six three double play
side is retired we go to the seventh
[Applause]
that's up the line is it there it is
williams didn't run
[Applause]
and marchand pops it up lindora out
almora in lindor makes the catch one two
three inning for may
last clicks for the match down one left
archie bradley is going to try to close
this out for the phillies here at the
bottom of the seventh inning
three two coming
and mckinney slashes one the other way
from bay sand
so billy mckinney breaks his over
and gives the mets life in the bottom of
the seventh with a pinch hit single nice
hitting right there
and luis slaps one to third bow can't
make the play and everybody's saved
terrible alec ball made an error in the
first game and he makes a crucial error
in the second game and the mets of the
tying and potential winning runs on base
nobody up in the philly bullpen behind
bradley
3-1 coming to conforto
and he checks the swing takes it low
ball four and the bases are loaded
so now james mccann and the phillies
look like they're going to drop back
their infield and try to turn a game
ending double play
and he hits it in the air to center
that'll at least tie it back goes
and herrera makes the catch
tagging is mckenney he comes in with the
time run
and almost beat herrera
but mccann got it deep enough to drive
on the top of the
and for the second game today the mets
have tied it in the bottom of the
seventh two outs bottom of the seventh
in a 1-1 game
ground ball
softly right side williams has it throws
to first and for a second consecutive
game
on the same day we are going
extra innings
so marchand will check out and jankowski
is going to pinch run
and the battery is odouble herrera
[Applause]
[Music]
but the phillies take the lead
okay yeah
speed puts pressure on the defense yep
and hector nearest is going to be the
new pitcher for the philly
swag
he got him and the phillies
win game two by a final score of two to
one in extra innings
thank goodness he went higher than high
they sure did